hey everybody welcome to another
rollback where we bring the best of our
pre-video catalog to youtube for the
very first time and today you're going
to be amazed you're going to be uplifted
by the incredible story of this week's
rollback with kim chambers one of the
most accomplished and inspiring
record-setting marathon open water
swimmers in the world
in 2015 kim set a new world record by
becoming the first woman to swim
30 miles through the red triangle off
the coast of san francisco which is the
largest concentration of great white
sharks in the world it was an absolute
pleasure to sit down with her in her
home in san francisco back in early 2017
she's delightful she's inspiring she's a
humble human everything you want in a
modern day female superhero
so this is a conversation about her
story of course
the boundaries of human potential
reframing setbacks as opportunities
how to shed old skins and step into your
most authentic fully actualized self and
many other topics
and i guess it's also about how to not
get eaten by a shark so anyway please
hit that subscribe button listen up and
enjoy episode 275
with kim chambers
well let's uh let's unpack it i want to
get into it your story is fascinating
i've been following you for quite some
time
um
and i think we made an effort to try to
hook this up a while back like i i took
a shot over the bow a while ago and she
didn't want to talk to you i don't
remember when that was and then uh i was
i had lunch with adam skolnick our
mutual friend yes he's like oh you're
going to san francisco you gotta you
gotta talk to kim and i was like that's
right i do i need to follow up on that
so i'm glad that we could make this
happen yeah no i'm just delighted to to
have you here so thank you well the
things you've done are extraordinary you
know world's greatest marathon open
water swimmer you've done so many and
and the challenge for me interviewing
you is to not make it like then you did
this and then you did that and then what
happened here you know what i mean but i
think in order to kind of create context
around the magnitude of the things that
that you've done
it behooves us to kind of take a step
back and and you know unpack the journey
that got you to this place because you
didn't grow up on swim teams swimming
wasn't your thing nope grew up in new
zealand right i grew up on a sheep and
kettle farm wow in the middle of nowhere
uh-huh
yeah and so you initially you were a
ballerina that was your thing right yeah
yeah i danced for 15 years actually
under
what's called the royal academy of
dancing and i set exams i traveled
around the country
performing on stage it was a huge part
of my life
and
you know i think that it's given me a
lot of um
skills for marathon swimming
you know
there's definitely this discipline that
we all know about ballerinas so
and that was um i mean that was the
dream to be a professional i mean what
do you call it professional ballerina
yeah yeah and then i you know i had a
growth spurt um i got too tall and then
it was sort of um the time that it took
for me to
you know study ballet and
school and have some sort of social life
there was a point where i had a sort of
a love-hate relationship with it because
you see all your friends out having fun
and
you know you're stuck in a studio it's
true of any you know elite athlete who's
trying to master their craft right as a
young person yeah and i experienced that
as a swimmer i mean of course you hear
the stories of gymnasts and tennis
players who are you know sort of locked
up in these you know prisons of
in her youth right i mean is that was it
that intense for you i mean it it
sometimes it felt that intense um but
once i sort of you know when i was sort
of i got 15 was when i really sort of
sprouted and in 5 10 now
then it was sort of clear that
you know that wasn't going to be my path
but i completed
all of my exams so that i became
qualified to teach so i danced until the
age of 17.
um
yeah and it's uh you know it was quite a
journey you learn a lot about yourself
um in ballet especially and like what
well it just
it looks so effortless
but it is quite the opposite
and
but there's been
you know what i learned as a ballerina
has really helped me with my swimming
but there have been a lot of differences
that i've had to
adjust to um you know as a ballerina
there was when i was dancing there was
no concept of really fueling your body
or really treating your body as this
um
machine
it was just you just wore it down that's
interesting because
you obviously want it to perform at its
peak and it's such a perfectionist
pursuit right oh absolutely
absolutely and then
you know i have an exceptionally high
pain tolerance and whether that's just
something that i've
always had or whether that was
through
you know years of ballet
i mean there were times when i would
take my feet out of my point shoes
and not know how much pain i was in
until i would see the blisters
dripping blood through my tights
just to be graphic wow
and then that connection in my brain was
like oh
yeah my feet are really sore now
so
that served me very well in swimming
actually you hear these stories of
of like cutthroat competition in ballet
right yeah a lot of eating disorders yes
yes yes kind of thing right yes you
experience those kind of pressures
you would definitely it was definitely
part of of that community um
and and maybe you know there were
a lot of us that had sort of disorders
with eating because you just
you know it's when you're not seeing
anyone else fuel their body or it's
you know you you're watching what your
your peers are doing um
and
you know that being able to have that
discipline to just keep pushing through
even if you are hungry but
it's just very strange very very strange
now they look back on it but then you
you have this growth spurt i mean if
there's probably not too many 510
ballerinas right like it doesn't work
anymore no
no
no that had to be a bummer
yeah you know um but you know i have
really little feet um which is not good
for swimming and i think they've that
was sort of stunted through years of
being on point
um so i joke that my feet have been
abound at a very young age um but yeah i
was too tall and
you know and i was more interested in
school as well and um i loved to study
and you know that sort of perfectionism
um definitely
wove its way through all aspects of my
life
so you start to teach when you learned
how to teach you learned how to teach
yeah qualified to do that but i didn't
actually teach you you didn't end up
doing that and so what brought you to
the united states yeah so i was a very
young 17 year old when i came here i
can't believe my parents let me go um
but my older brother had been recruited
to uc berkeley to row
and
i was fascinated by the fact that he was
over here in america and
you know i traveled as a child with my
family but you know to go to college in
america was just something
so um
amazing to me at the time and
um so i actually set the sats at my
school
and got into a few schools and chose
berkeley
because my brother was there and so i
ended up
going to cal with my big brother
and
they actually
recruited me onto the rowing team
because they said basically well you're
tall
you're very coordinated and you've got
great genes because of your brother and
i mean i had high pain threshold yeah
but i had no upper body strength like i
was not meant to be aurora so
i tried it for a few years but um
let's just say i wasn't that good uh-huh
and you're what does your brother still
live out here yeah he does what does he
do uh he lives on the east coast he's in
property management and uh he doesn't
row anymore but
you know we still have these really
close bonds with all of those teammates
and that was real team sport for me
um
and all hit all the guys on his team
were like my big brothers at cal so i
felt pretty lucky uh-huh good so you're
already multi-disciplinary in your in
your athleticism yeah right yeah and so
let's fast forward to the the kind of um
you know catalyst that spurned you into
what you do today right you suffered
this this terrible accident yeah yeah i
am
a total freak accident on my way to work
um
and i look back and gosh i didn't even
know who i was at that time i was um
working in silicon valley
working long hours making pretty good
amounts of money and
um
i was on my way to work like any other
day and i used to wear really high heels
um you know it's all about the outfit
right um
and i slipped down the staircase where i
was living
and my
um i was wearing a pantsuit and i think
that caught on my heel
went flying down the staircase
i hit my head
and i
hit my right leg on this
big ceramic pot that i had at the bottom
of the staircase and um
i actually didn't break any bones i mean
people break their necks flying down
staircases i was just in a hurry um not
thinking and
my first thought is like i'm just gonna
have a really bad bruise on my leg it's
just gonna be a really bad bruise i
gotta get to work so i went to work i
drove to work meanwhile my leg is
swelling
um what i was diagnosed with is called
acute compartment syndrome and it
actually
is often misdiagnosed if you're at the
hospital in the initial phases of it
because
sometimes it takes a while for your leg
to actually swell
what happened with me is i eventually
passed out from the pain and um i'm
waking up after they've performed the
first of many surgeries on my leg did
you pass out at work yeah so what did
they get an ambulance yeah so i ended up
in a hospital here in san francisco
and
um my leg
i mean i'm trying to show you here my
leg was probably i have i'll show you
the photos later today but it was
swollen right out to here um so about
four or five inches on each side of my
calf muscle wow
um and again it's from blunt force
trauma to a limb
and they performed a surgery called a
fasciotomy where they cut through the
fascia
and i've learned so much through this
but the
fascia protects your muscles and it it
doesn't give
and so the pressure was building up in
my legs and the nerves were getting
compressed and dying
so i i still have significant nerve
damage in my right leg
but
when the doctors came into my room
after they've done the first surgery
and i have
you know they've just sliced me on each
side of my calf muscle
i have two big gaping holes
um
[Music]
and they're telling me you know we saved
your leg but we don't know if you'll
ever be able to use it again wow
and you know they you know i i we all
have so weird like it like it didn't
break the bone i didn't break so that
trauma was so significant that
inflammation was so intense that it
damaged all the surrounding areas yeah
it just um it causes this depression to
build up so it can happen in any of your
limbs um
but it's it's from blunt force trauma so
people in car accidents get it
um
and
i mean
you know i'm learning as i get older we
have defining moments in our lives right
and
i i really
have never forgotten those words and and
at that moment when
the surgeon said that to me
i i knew for whatever reason that i
there were two choices for me one was to
like basically accept that
um that you know all of my mobility all
of all of that which i took for granted
was gone and be essentially disabled
or i could you know prove them wrong and
um
that was what i decided to do i didn't
know how i was going to do it um but how
do you think that you were able to make
that decision as opposed to sink into a
depression or kind of create an identity
around you know being a victim yeah
that's an interesting question i mean i
have
i mean i think just growing up on a farm
and knowing that you just have to get
stuck in and you just have to get things
done and
i was so
like horrified that
this had happened it wasn't like
it wasn't like a a traumatic
you know skiing accident or a car
accident it was like i was on my way to
work and it was just
this disbelief that this was
my reality um
and i
like yesterday everything was fine right
and my friends call me this sort of the
energizer bunny i go and go and go and
go go i don't sit still for very long
and i was completely
incapacitated um and that was the first
of many surgeries that i had how long
ago was this um coming up on 10 years
ago
yeah um and i
you know initially i was horrified with
the scars you know i look back and i was
like gosh i was so
living such a superficial life then and
i really feel like
you're now i mean at the time i thought
it was the worst possible thing that
could ever happen to me because it
it took two years out of my life because
it took me that long to walk again
um wow so you were you were in a
wheelchair and then crutches for no i
was on crutches um but they
after i transitioned out of crutches and
i had multiple surgeries uh later like i
have a big skin graft taken from my
thigh once the swelling went down it
took nine months for the swelling of my
leg to go down
so then they're patching up those you
know the big
holes on the side of my leg with the
skin from my thigh
then um i had to do physical therapy i
did that full time and
you know the applying the discipline of
having been a ballerina
i applied that to
um
getting better i mean they they said i
was their perfect patient because
i never missed a physical therapy
appointment i think there was one
because i was sick
but i just i gave it everything i didn't
work it was that was my job and my job
was to
fix this to be
healthy and to be the person i was
before um
it's a beautiful thing when you can look
back on something like that and
recognize it as an opportunity for
growth yes i'm sure it wasn't fun in the
midst of it and perhaps you didn't you
weren't able to sort of recognize that
at the time but right it's always
magical when
you can kind of take a ten thousand foot
view and look down and say not that you
brought that into your life or that you
did anything wrong or anything like that
right the universe kind of knocks on
your door in a way and says yes hey
maybe you should look
you know in a little bit of a different
direction for your life yes and i really
feel like because i am such a focused
person in some ways
i needed
to have my life completely derailed
to go in a different direction
and and sorry to interrupt but at that
time you were pursuing the silicon
valley dream right were you is that was
that the idea or what's going on i mean
i you know i had my i i you know
graduated i you know i did my undergrad
at berkeley but i went back and i got my
masters of science at berkeley and
um you know i was working at big tech
companies and
really having money for the first time
um
and just
really
a really superficial life now that i
look back on it but
that those two years when i was
rehabilitating my leg and and
and my sense of self really
because i don't like to ask for help
and i had to get help for everything
but at the time i thought it was the
worst possible thing that could ever
happen to me
and now i mean
i tell anyone that well listen i'm like
that was the best thing that ever
happened to me the absolute
best thing because
it set me on a journey that
i could never have dreamed of if you'd
asked me 10 years ago if i'd be
sitting here talking about
my swimming journey or having had the
experiences i've had i would think you
were mad
that that wasn't wouldn't be possible um
but i learned what i was made of in
those two years right and and the
stripping down of your ego and you're
being compelled to be so humbled to your
core
absolutely creates like a fertile ground
for rebirth absolutely and it was it
really was a rebirth um
and
it just
you know i look back like i look at my
life now and
um
my my soul is so rich um
and i have this community that is just
an amazing group of
adventurers that
you know have these sort of double lives
they work in tech or they work in
government and then they
swim in cold water for crazy distances
in their free time and it's just the
it's opened up my world of possibility
of um not only myself but of like the
human spirit
i have my version of of your story
that's very different in in certain ways
but i think the the arc is very similar
you know because i sit here and i'm like
what am i even doing here sitting with
you having this cover you know like i
would have never mapped that out for my
life
and the things that i've done and the
stuff that i do and i would imagine the
idea that you would be like a marathon
you know open water swimmer like what
like right you'd probably i'm sure you
had no i didn't even know that that was
something that existed like so
it's so beautiful that
you know an experience like that could
like just
sort of reform every aspect of how you
live your life and perceive the world
yeah and i mean even just talking to you
now it chokes me up because i
i don't every day for me is a total gift
and
you know that's why i get up in the
morning and i swim even though you know
we've had these crazy storms and it's
freezing cold and your body and your
mind saying what are you doing
every time it's doing that but you just
we only have one life and you never know
the direction it's gonna take and
um
and then when you find a community of
people that nobody's saying well why
would you do that or that's a silly idea
they say
that's a great idea
even if it is
you know this crazy swim idea well your
friends at the tech company might not
have said that no
no they walk wide circles around me even
today
but it's just um
yeah it
look my life is so full and it's just
through
the sport this crazy sport called
marathon open water swimming but it's
more than that it's full because you
opened your heart to
a different possibility for yourself and
you had the courage to pull on that
thread and follow it you know it might
have sound insane yeah and to continue
to follow it yeah and that's that's
where the work part of it comes in and
the courage and the faith yeah
yeah yeah and
really um
you know i think we have it in all of us
to pick ourselves up um you know and
life is this journey where you you know
you don't know what's going to happen
next um but it's
having that ability somehow to really
reach deep inside yourself and and and
pull yourself out of a situation um
it's easier said than done i know that
but um and it's not to say that i didn't
go down some deep dark holes
in those two years when um you know i i
couldn't i still walked with a limp and
you know my scars were just
so you know
angry
red so pronounced and i was just
horrified
um but you know when i first
got in the pool i mean that was
you know it had been two years of um
being a patient really for two years
um and definitely feeling
other i didn't feel myself and having
been a ballerina you're acutely aware of
when your body is misaligned and when
it's not right
and that's how i felt every day
and i had to wear an ankle foot orthotic
it's called an afo i had to put that in
sneakers so i couldn't wear you know
nice fancy heel
heels and so it was just like my life is
you know it's just when i think back
it's just oh my goodness but
i craved
a sense of freedom
uh
so much that i
was willing
to put myself
in a swimsuit in a pool in front of
people because i
you know i'd learned water safety as a
kid in new zealand that how we sort of
grew up and i'd always played in the
waves as a kid in the summer i liked the
water
but my swimming style was pretty
terrible well what what got you to the
pool in the first place like did
somebody say hey let's go swim or like
what what was the initial trigger
well it was just this frustration of
feeling stuck i couldn't
you know san francisco is a great
walking city and i couldn't even walk up
hills i i just
i just felt trapped i felt really really
trapped and i was looking for
freedom
and
i just subconsciously was drawn to the
water um so wait all right so that's
interesting so in kind of a mystical way
it was like pulling you or calling you
yeah so it wasn't like some friend
dragged you to the pool or
anything like that like there was just
some
uh unconscious
tug yes yes and i guess just to feel
weightless um
to feel
yeah just to feel a sense of
of freedom um
and so there's a great outdoor pool here
in san francisco called golden gateway
it's right along the embarcadero
oh yeah it's a lovely pool it's a great
place to get a tan and swim
and
i just started i went there by myself
and i got in and i remember the first
time i got to the pool and i was just
like oh my gosh everyone's going to be
staring at my scars this is disgusting
this is gross i just felt just
not myself but
i realized that when i got in the pool
you know you're standing there waist
deep and nobody was looking at my scars
they were just looking at me and um you
know i'd swim some laps and then
somebody said if you swim 80 laps that's
a mile i think it was actually incorrect
now someone's told me that
okay well i was doing a bit more than
depending upon how long the pool is yeah
yeah so and i decided that
i wouldn't get out of the pool until i'd
done 80 laps
first time yes and that was what i set
my mind to and so every time i went down
there that was what i did
and i've just been swimming there for a
month and a couple of guys at the pool
um
first of all before we even get to that
like just the experience of being in the
water i mean did you have that sensation
of like
i'm home or this is this is
i am getting that sensation of freedom
that i was looking for yeah it was it
wasn't it didn't feel like home yet um
but it was a sense of freedom and then
just
it was so good for me mentally because
i was just like everybody else i mean my
stroke was pretty bad but
i was moving across the water just like
everybody else whereas when i was on
land
everything was just clunky and and you
know i had this afo which is a big
plastic thing that goes
the back of your calf and
slips into your shoe and it has a little
hinge so you can pick up your foot
but in the water i was just like
everybody else i was just wearing a
swimsuit there was no other extra
equipment
um so that was really the
the real um like freedom from from
judgment of others and judgment of self
yes yes and i think there was more
judgment of self
to be honest i think we we always worry
about what other people think and
they're really not thinking what we're
thinking you know
but when you're feeling um
vulnerable and you're feeling sensitive
it can be really overwhelming
yeah i think you know i i have
i had i had a similar thing in high
school it was it was emotional it wasn't
physical but like going to swim practice
was
safe yeah you know and it was free and
underwater
you could unshackle yourself from
those internal that internal dialogue
yes and the external pressures of the
world yes
yes yes it became a sanctuary
yeah yeah so then a couple guys come up
to you yeah and they're now very good
friends of mine and
they said to me
have you ever thought about swimming in
the san francisco bay and i'd only been
swimming at the pool for about a month
and i was like
but i've been living in the bay area
since 1995 and i was like
that's ridiculous it's cold and aren't
there sharks and
all these things were going through my
head but
it was a bit of a dare and
i'll do anything for you recruited into
some strange religion yeah the foot
soldiers are trying to pull you in
some bizarre cult yeah and i didn't know
and they were kind of cute and i was
like well you know and i'll
i'll challenge guys on a dare you know
like i don't know how i'm going to do
this
but i'll do it
and so i said okay what do i need and
they said just a swimsuit
um cap and goggles
and they gave me when i got there they
gave me one of these old school sort of
thermal caps
and
i i have that experience on video and
that was because they thought i was just
gonna have this like freak out and just
be
like a total girl and like
down at aquatic park here yeah and it
was in november of 2009. so this is
going into winter
and
it was freezing cold
and the water temperature was 50 54 55
and at the time you know i'd lost so
much
conditioning you know
after i'd finished college i was pretty
much a gym rat
i work out all the time
but because i'd been incapacitated i'd
lost all
um
you know definition i was probably i was
really skinny i was probably about 120
pounds soaking wet
um
and i'll show you the video and i'm on
the beach and by comparison now you know
when you're when you're ramping up for
one of these challenges you get up to
like 180 right 195.
yeah okay we'll get there but keep going
my ballet mistress would be horrified
yeah um i do remember her saying to us a
moment on the lips a lifetime on the
hips for the food i just thought of that
right now that's that's healthy yeah
exactly
um
but yeah and i'm standing on the beach
and um and i
have it all this it what
i didn't know at the time was going to
be another defining moment for my life
and
they're sort of talking me through um
you know and i'm standing there and i'm
like my legs are numb and they're like
your whole body's gonna be numb in about
three minutes
and then i was just like okay i'm just
gonna go for it
and i dive in and my stroke i mean
looking back it's just my legs are
flopping up and it's just
but i got out there in the middle of the
cove um aquatic park is this wonderful
sort of
um
little enclosure there's no motorized
boats are allowed there there's like
little sailboats are allowed there
people row there and it's a really safe
place to to swim but
you're in the bay and there's seals out
there and sea birds and right for people
that are listening it's right at the
foot of ghirardelli square in san
francisco and it's kind of there's like
piers that jut out or jetties that kind
of protect this swimming area yeah right
and there's a little clubhouse the
dolphin club clubhouse we're going to
talk about the dolphin club but
yeah and every time you go by there
you'll see some nut cases or swimming
and you're like what are they doing yeah
yeah so i'm one of those now um
but i got out there and i just
i remember just stopping and
jordan who was swimming next to me he's
like i've never seen anyone grin ear to
ear like i was just lit up
because i looked out there and i was
like
this is exactly what i've been looking
for this this is it and that was a
feeling of
i'm home wow it was
like i
my whole body
came alive um i just it was such an
electrifying experience to just
i could see
new possibilities for myself i would of
course i wouldn't imagine what i've done
since then but
i was it was complete freedom for me and
i could smell the ocean and it was just
this adventure um
right here in the city
i wasn't in for very long because it was
very cold
but uh
i've i've basically been swimming in the
bay every day since that's amazing rain
or shine i have gone and swam at aquatic
park maybe a handful of times i did not
have that experience
i enjoyed it it was cool but it wasn't
like a lights-on moment for me i was
like okay i did it you know yeah for me
it was it was a reboot yeah that's right
that's yeah it's beautiful yeah you know
yeah yeah and i i wish you know i wish
that experience on everybody
yeah i i i try to recruit many people to
the bay and
it's sort of i joke that it's sort of a
baptism
of the soul
because it's just um and what part of
that is
the cold versus just you know maybe
other aspects of it like is what what is
the fundamental component of the cold
water like the impact of that on that
experience
well i think it's because
every time you get in the water it it
really like as i said your mind and your
body are saying this is ridiculous this
is not a good idea this is
you need to go get warm
but being able to
push through that moment when you
doubt yourself or youth
you think you're cold you think you
can't do it
to be able to just
dive in and push through that
you literally come out on the other side
and you're like i did that even though i
was cold even though i didn't get much
sleep last night i did it and i'm out
here and
then it really sort of sets up your day
because you've really
conquered the hardest thing of your day
right at the beginning but it is
the sensation of the cold water is um
it's very strange
um
you know it affects people differently
but it is certainly refreshing um
i mean you
your endorphins
are fired up um
you're clearly awake and
there's sort of this giddiness um
with being in cold water and
also out there it it sort of connects
with
a playfulness that i think we forget
about as adults
just to be able to frolic out there and
i'll see seals and sea lions and i mean
people think i'm mad because i talk to
them like they're dogs and they respond
to me they kind of are dogs they are
they're dog mermaids very dog-like yeah
yeah and to have an interaction where
they're just
as far away as you are as close as you
are right now to me across this table
where they just look at you and you can
see their eyelashes and
you can talk to them and
this connection and and to be
you know and swims that i've done since
to be
fundamentally accepted
in
an environment for which really humans
shouldn't be in
um i think also
in my limited experience in cold water
from a mindfulness perspective
it it shuts down that part of your brain
that kind of runs on automatic in the
background all the time like it forces
you to be very present with yourself
because you are in this heightened state
yes there's no room for oh i gotta call
that guy or i didn't pay that bill or
all that stuff gets crowded out yep and
you're just you have this palpable sense
of just being in the moment and being
hyper alive that's uh yeah that's an
excellent observation that's exactly it
you you have to be in the moment and
equally nothing else in the world
matters which is
wonderful um and and
i can guarantee whatever is on your mind
whatever is troubling you and you know
we all have bad days or we're worried
about current events or whatever
for a brief moment however long you're
in the water
none of that matters
it's just you
in nature
um and it's
for me here it's right here in the city
right so you can have your urban life
yeah have this incredibly primal
you know life as well it is very very
primal um you know your your body
becomes very in tune with the
surroundings
for us for those of us that are in the
water every day
we can pretty much guess the water
temperature within half a degree
just because of how our body feels
um and then there's a sense of smell and
it's
it really is very very primal
so you're all in from the first moment
right all in and then and i'm all or
nothing kind of person anyway yeah i
gather
i get that is it obvious right
so then talk to me a little bit about
uh the culture of the dolphin club which
is the swim club that kind of looms over
that aquatic park in the history like
it's this
legendary club that dates back quite a
long time right yeah there's a and
there's actually two clubs there
um side by side i didn't know about that
yeah so there's the dolphin club and the
south end rowing club they're rivals
um but i'm a middle child and i belong
to both
and i'm all in too so i'm like i want i
want all of it and
they're quite different clubs everybody
is
um joined together with a love of
either being in the water or on the
water there's a rowing program for both
clubs
but they are
it's really
like a secret society of adventurers
and we all have day jobs we're all um
you know working in various aspects in
the city and beyond
but when you come there it's it doesn't
matter
it's a it's a complete cross-section of
society
unlike any other club i know of
it doesn't matter how much money you
have doesn't matter what color you are
it doesn't matter what you do for a
living that doesn't even come up sounds
like aaa oh really
yeah i think we're all addicts down
there it's just a swim addiction
it is very much a swim addiction
um but you you come together and
the bonds that you have with these
people are so deep because
it really is like this little secret
society and
everyone watches out for each other
but it's like this
every day it's like a little sitcom
that's played out and
um
you know
all ages the the oldest woman at the
dolphin club that's currently swimming
is 80 years old
her name's mimi and she gets in the
water every day
wearing just a regular swimsuit
and i can tell you when you're on the
beach a little cold
wondering whether you can do it because
every day that happens and you see me
saunter on then it's just like oh okay
right i can't not get in you know not
that i've ever not gotten in but you
know and
it's just
it's really wonderful to have those
connections with older folks as well
and uh
you know we have
a club swims we have uh swims against
the other club
and
the camaraderie there is just like just
fills the walls it's amazing and there's
a there's this beautiful tradition as
well right like i said it dates this is
not a new organization not right these
people there's people that have been
doing it for a very long time since
1877. oh is it that old wow
yeah wow yeah yeah and you look at the
pictures on the walls of the the
swimsuits they used to wear back then
and they only let women into the club in
1977
oh really yes yes yes so um
what would happen if somebody goes down
there and has a wetsuit on oh no it's
totally fine oh it is it is it is out of
there
no but
you can't compete in the club swims
wearing a wetsuit um but
yeah no you you can wear a wetsuit um
but you know people sort of have each
other on and you know like oh you don't
need that and but
we all swim within our own limits
um
i think everyone should try at least
once
getting in their order without a wetsuit
because it's
that's right
many years ago i did the alcatraz swim
without a wetsuit
and all i remember i remember a couple
it was i can't remember it must have
been
94.95 something like that
and it was not summer you know i don't
know that it was maybe it was october or
march or something like that um
and uh all i remember about that is
when i got into when i was way in the
middle like about the halfway point it's
not a long swim it's only like a mile
and a half right yep yep
like halfway in you realize like oh
you're like in a shipping lane like
you're not this is not like some
pristine lake like
it's gnarly yeah you know yeah and then
my hands and my feet went completely
numb so i felt like i just was swimming
with fists
you know it was exhilarating but i also
you know i was like i i don't know it's
for me you know like i did it and i did
fine and it was
fun i did it with my friends and the
other thing i remember about that is i
don't remember who the race organized
organizer was there was a series of
these races
but the guy who conducted who who who
organized the race had a dog like a bla
it was like a lab i think
and this
lab
his favorite thing was to do the
alcatraz like he was so excited like his
favorite he was you could tell he just
couldn't wait to get in the water and
the dog dog paddles the whole thing and
beats half the field
well they do have webb's feeds
that's right
and four legs so when does the uh when
does the spark to try to tackle a
challenge come in does that is that a
gradual progression of doing these sort
of competitions between the swim clubs
or
what happens well it was just i i was
just
without knowing i i'd sort of
dropped into this
community of amazing people um and on
the wall as a as a
record of all the people who have soloed
the english channel you get your name
there and your time that it took you to
cross the channel and i remember
i would just
marvel
at that wall because
these are people that i was interacting
with on a daily basis that it's won the
english channel and
i just started to see
possibilities and
you know i had a lot of encouragement
from people um who at the club who would
just like you know
say well i can help you train for that
or i can you know i know somebody has
done that but it really it was my first
in the year 2010 um
i did my first alcatraz
that was six months after joining the
club
and i did it on my birthday
and i called it the first annual kiwi
invitational escape from alcatraz
i had my new zealand flag it wasn't like
a wreck you just did it it was an
organized swim yeah and i
i can remember stopping mid-channel and
looking at alcatraz and then looking at
san francisco and i was like
i'm doing this i'm really swimming from
alcatraz and
what happened for me is i discovered
that if i did one thing well maybe i can
do this next thing
and
then in early 2011
i was introduced to a group of swimmers
called the night train swimmers veto yes
vitobiala
he's a very very good friend and a
mentor for me and he actually
he was the person who believed in me
when nobody believed in me um he invited
me to join the team
um and he said that i couldn't swim my
way out of a paper bag with flippers on
and he was totally right
but he saw something in me and he
invited me what did he see in you
he says that he saw tenacity and drive
um
and
certainly not swimming uh
there needed to be a lot of work on that
but at the time they were um attempting
to swim to the farallon islands
and now the farallon islands are 30
miles off the coast of california here
it's
marine sanctuary but it's you know where
great white sharks frequent and some of
the largest are there and they like to
breed there let's just paint the picture
you know you're making it sound a little
bit more idyllic than i think it is if
anybody's been to san francisco or
driven across the golden gate bridge as
you look out you know to the ocean side
as you're crossing that bridge
uh if it's a clear day you can just make
them out and they're like these
foreboding jutting rocks that stick up
out of the ocean that just are look
about as treacherous as you can possibly
imagine like it's out of lord of the
rings or something like that like it is
it is frightening just to
imagine taking a boat out there let
alone swimming and then understand that
it is this incredible
uh nature preserve where i mean you know
thousands and thousands of sea lions and
seals kind of breed there right
and as a result of that it is like the
red triangle of great white sharks
it is it is for me it yeah i mean i
it's a it's a fantasy world out there
for me um and i can explain more but
it was vito and the night train swimmers
that thought that that was a very good
idea to swim to those islands
and they had been attempting to do
a relay swim so with a relay
you have six swimmers and you swim in
hour long shifts until you get you
rotate through until you get to your
destination
and vito's got his boat right so yeah
right yeah yeah yeah and he's an expert
um you know um captain and he's also a
swimmer and among many other things but
he
um
he came up with this idea and there'd
been many attempts because it's such a
it's a treacherous stretch of water and
it's very
um it's just tricky with the currents
with the winds there's only a handful of
days when it's actually the best time to
swim there
so he asked me to accompany them on the
boaters support crew
and it was just this wild
wild wild west out there
um and i was just captivated by all of
it
and then
the the last relay which was actually
the successful one i was invited to be
on the team someone dropped out
and i but that first time they didn't
they weren't successful it took four
attempts
and i was on the fourth one i was the
only woman on um this co-ed team and i
remember when vito left me the message
to tell me um
that i was on the team he's like
this is the message you've been waiting
for this is the phone call you've been
waiting for you're on the team and i
felt like my christmas had just come
early i was like i can't believe i'm
gonna be part of this
followed quickly by
a sheer terror
no you know well also because i wasn't
the best swimmer and you know when
you're a part of a team you don't want
to be that one that lets everyone down
so he i feel like he really took a
gamble with me but um
again he believed in me and i'll never
forget that
so we were out there and um
david holsher on our team was the person
who actually finished the swim he had to
slap a buoy because you can't touch the
land there
and it was just before the sun was about
to set
so you take the boat out to the
fairlawns and you swim back no we swam
too
okay yeah yeah and you know they had
never been done before and
we because it's a marine sanctuary we
had these permits to
another permit to do it again
and i said to vito i said you know it'd
be such a waste to give up that permit
could i put together the first all
women's team
to do that relay and he's like sure you
know he's he's always up for adventure
so within two weeks i managed to recruit
five other women
um i managed to convince them that it
was a good idea to swim in shark
infested water
um
and they are five of the strongest
woman bravest woman i know
and we completed the relay and
i actually ended up being the last
person to get in that water and it was
dark and
you know you don't want to be the one
that lets down the team but that was
definitely a moment of truth where you
are a mile out from the fairlawns you're
about to set another record you've got
your team they've done all their work
and now it's just up to you to do the
last leg
but the last leg of course being the
hardest because uh not only is it you've
been out there so long but now you're
entering the shark infested part and
it's dark and it's dark and we've got
video and there's just this you just see
this little blue light on the back of my
goggles
and you see the silhouette of the
islands and i
i watch it from time to time because
you know you do these things but it
takes a long time to sink in
and i mean it was crazy
and
you know i remember when david holster
finished the swim and he slapped the
buoy and in this moment of just
thinking i'm going to get eaten by a
shark and the adrenaline is just surging
through your body like it
it's an incredible feeling
um i decided to kiss the buoy
and then because the water was so
treacherous
i'm expecting to just be hauled onto the
boat
and then the boat moves away from me i'm
like vito like i'm not a prima donna i'm
not high maintenance but i just finished
the swim and i need to get on the boat i
need to get out of this water because
i'm on a ticking time bomb yeah but it
was too rough and so i had to actually
had to swim to the boat but what is the
perimeter around the farallons that sort
of like how far away do you have to be
before you're kind of a little bit free
and clear of the shark infestation five
miles oh wow it's
a lot broader yeah that's what they call
the the ecosystem
yeah
yeah and so it's you know you
i had these experiences i was like
i just want to do more i just that
feeling of being out there
when you're in water that's
six thousand ten thousand feet deep and
you're just this little
person on the top of the of the surface
of the water and
your mind just goes crazy thinking about
what's swimming underneath you and for
me it's just this
wonderland out there
you know we've gone back there on the
weekends just to frolic in the water
there and i'll come back to work and
people like oh how was your weekend i
was like well you know i just did a
little dip at the pharaoh you know and i
do videos and i put music to it and it's
just
but it um so i became
[Music]
i started to have a love affair with
those islands
and um
that sort of set
um a goal
what is it about those islands that make
it so special is it the treachery is it
is it the
the
the the challenge of of
meeting your fear on such a profound
level yes yes and very much so it it
it's like
being in heaven and
talking to the devil at the same time to
quote veto
he summed it up pretty well like it is
it is a wonderland out there you know
when i've gone out there on the weekends
and there's
the visibility
is incredible sort of 50 feet either
direction you've got all these seals and
sea lions and
they'll come right up to you and if
they're swimming underneath you and
darting underneath you and
um
and you know that you're really not
supposed to be there because a shark
could come out of nowhere
and it's not like any of us are on sort
of this
death wish but
you really are i think it is
tantalizing to to to be
at that at that right at that edge i
mean that is and super connected yes
yes um
it's like i i if i could go to the
farallons every day i would
it's it is um
[Music]
it really is just this
like i said it's a wonderland and
and again to be accepted by
the the the creatures that frequent that
water and
i have i haven't had a shark encounter
out there
um you know they're there right you can
feel them i know like when you did your
solo swim you had like a uh like a sonic
thing on your ankle right like it's some
kind of
sonar thing that's supposed to repel the
sharks yeah it lets off a magnetic wave
um sort of creates a magnetic field
around you whether it works or not i
don't know but um
most importantly though it doesn't harm
the sharks
i feel
you know some people have said to me
like is your boat gonna have a shotgun
on it and
it's like no you know that is
that's their living room antithetical to
the whole idea absolutely i
and you know and i i i do these sort of
um i'm more of a spiritual person but
the times i've gone out there i just
sort of say you know like i pray for a
safe passage and i'm just passing
through
like that is that is their living room
and it has to be treated with the utmost
respect
right if you came in
from an aggressive an aggressive point
of view and you did have a gun and you
did you know all these things it's
almost like the energy that you would be
bringing to that area would be very
different yeah you would be inviting a
problem as opposed to
i mean what it is really is total
surrender you're like i'm here
this is what's what's going to happen is
going to happen and a complete letting
go which is
terrifying but also plays into what you
were saying about freedom it is it
really is i mean i you know i i control
what i can control leading up to the
swim but
there is nothing more exhilarating than
jumping off that boat into that water
for any of these swims and it is
not knowing and
that for me is captivating it it
because we live a life on land where we
think we know what's gonna happen and
you walk out the door and you're gonna
walk down the street and you're gonna
get in your car and you're gonna drive a
certain everything seems so prescribed
you know even looking at road signs
where it's like oh caution there's a
curve ahead
when you're out there it it again it's
it's so primal and you are at the mercy
of mother nature you're at the mercy of
whatever could happen there and it is
every time i'm out there i
i i surrender and it is so freeing um
it's so scary
but it's
i mean it's everything it's just
and you feel like this modern day
explorer like i feel like
an astronaut out there that i i'm in an
area where
humans well in the history of humankind
how many people have actually gotten
into the water around the fairlawns
not many people you take the night train
swimmers out of that equation maybe a
couple yeah i think there's four four um
three men and um myself wow
and
yeah and i would i would do it again
heartbeat
so you did the relay yeah and then what
comes next is the idea of doing the what
is it called the seven uh the ocean
seven seven so what happened after that
was i thought well i can't believe i've
done that what's the next thing i need
to do the next adventure
and i'd signed up to swim around the
island of manhattan in new york in a
relay
and
did that with a team of guys and i'd
signed up to swim across the english
channel in a relay
that all that same year and i was living
with a bunch of guys
it was basically a frat house but they
were all they're all like my buddies and
they're adventurous and one of my
roommates had climbed mount everest and
he'd swam the endless channel
and he's sitting on my rug with his dog
and we're talking about my getting ready
to go to england and he's like you know
you're going to england in a couple
weeks to do your relay like
you're spending all this money why you
just do a solo while you're there and i
was like enough with this relay nonsense
i was like that's a great idea
i had no business doing that absolutely
no business when i started to tell
people because i was so excited
they were just like you are absolutely
insane um
and
you know
there's so much work that goes into a
solo and um
a part of me still wanted to pull a
rabbit out of her head and
well the logistics also all the
permitting and all of that is a
major ordeal yeah so it all came
together but um i was not prepared and i
i think i wasn't even halfway across and
they pulled me and
i definitely came back with my tail
between my legs i was very
i was very disappointed in myself
but
i decided that i would come back there
and i would complete that swim and i
would be as qualified as possible
so then i started to think about okay
what could be my first real
solo and
at the time my um my grandfather my
maternal grandfather was in ill health
and
you know he really was the the proudest
kiwi i've ever known
and i was like i'm gonna swim from the
south island to the north island in new
zealand across the cook strait
and
how many miles is that about 17 miles
there's also sharks that frequent there
um of course yeah one in six apparently
um encounter they use that word a bit
loosely but
uh i made it across wait one in six wait
one in six people that get in the water
there encounter a shark yes okay yes yes
and it's one of the few swimmers
yes yes
um and it's one of the few swims where
you are allowed so for all of these solo
swims you cannot touch your boat get on
the boat at any time but
um with the farallons and with the cook
straight you can get on the boat for 10
minutes
i don't know who can get in the water
after 10 minutes after having seen a
shark but right the option is there for
you because they make that exception
because of the sharks yeah right yeah
yeah so
um
yeah and that swim uh was an incredible
swim for me i mean i was on home turf
and this was what like 2010 or this was
march of 2012. okay yeah so 2011 was my
relay year got it and then 2012 was
march of 2012
i had dolphins escort me
and that was my first experience of that
and they were swimming underneath me
beside me i was so close i could almost
reach their dorsal fins
but i heard them squeak in the water
first and
it was just like oh my gosh the cavalry
is here you know they're gonna carry
these angels are gonna escort you yeah
and the fact that they knew that i was a
friend and not a foe and
i joke now i'm like you know i'm sure
they were talking amongst themselves and
being like george like what is this
thing in the water like what she can't
even swim like should we be worried
about her like what's she doing you know
i'm sure they were like talking
but they would squeak and i would squeak
back and so
i mean really like i'm like a 12 year
old girl out there because it's just
i mean
it
it's so special every time but to have
these dolphins escort me for about 40 45
minutes
they were so close to me
and i i think they were protecting me um
but i didn't see any sharks on my swim
and and i finished the swim
i
i had to go to hospital afterwards i was
a little hypothermic
how cold is that water
uh it's about
it was about
57 57 degrees that's not too bad yeah
yeah but i was also you know i've sort
of
you i've learned you how to
put weight on and you know you with each
swim you learn more about how to train
and
you know and i got to show my
grandfather the video of me swimming
with the dolphins and before he passed
away but
so i'd done that and then um i swam the
length of lake tahoe
um
and
that was an interesting swim because
there's nothing quite like training at
sea level for an altitude swim i was
violently ill for most of it yeah um
it's no joke at tahoe i've done that
trans tahoe
relay and you know just without doing
any preparation at altitude to go up
there you're like whoa
yeah yeah yeah but it was a challenge
and
you know and and this video of me
getting out of the water and i'm just in
tears because it's just um
every time for me
there's this disbelief that really
when you put your mind and your body to
a goal
and then you achieve it
it's just you can't even quite
comprehend it
and i must say that for each of these
swims i've had a team of people
escorting me
and there's nothing solo about any of
these swims right you don't just show up
and jump in there's a whole you know
ramp up and it's very you know organized
from the person driving the boat to the
person you know keeping an eye on you
cheering you on like
you can't do this alone and that has
also been a wonderful
learning for me to be able to ask for
help and receive it
you know because i wasn't like that
before
so did lake tahoe
and we'd done then we attempted another
night train relay down the coast we were
attempting to swim from san francisco to
santa barbara oh i remember that yeah
and i got stung by jellyfish so
each evening shift of mine
the sun was sitting and the moon was
rising and you could just see the
jellyfish rise to the surface and
they're called siphonophores they're
actually not the gelatinous
ones that we think of with jellyfish
they're actually like look like little
snakes
it was like being tasered for your whole
hour
and i have a high pain tolerance but um
it got to the point where i had
difficulty breathing and we got tomorrow
bay and we had to call a swim right and
you can go into anaphylactic shock right
yeah
it was the right call but i
i was i was really devastated because
i was the one they were the one yeah
right and nobody blamed me but
i blame myself and
then could you get stopped by jellyfish
how dare you right
and so then people were saying well kim
you know you we know you love your
swimming but
i don't think you can swim in water with
jellyfish anymore and i was like
i think i'm going to try and prove you
wrong
so i think once that happens you become
more susceptible the next time you're
attacked right yeah yeah yeah so i was
like well
i'd like to test that theory
and i don't like being told i can't do
something so clearly
so there's this stretch of water in
hawaii called the molokai channel from
molokai to oahu
um
tiger sharks portuguese manowar so
you've got a whole menu of right at
least it's warm now yes that one's
longer though right how far is that
about 35 miles
and um
so the water temperature was just
amazing and i got in at night 8 30 at
night and finished almost 20 hours later
um i got stung a few times for
portuguese man of war and i remember
just trying to scrape off the tentacles
off my with my swimsuit
um
i had dolphins escort me in the middle
of the night and lit up with a
bioluminescent glow and
and then towards the end i had humpback
whales singing
and in hawaii they call it armakula that
that's your ancestors speaking to you
and i thought that that was my
grandfather so
but then i
because the conditions deteriorated i
was supposed to exit at sandy's beach
on oahu which freaked me out anyways
because i'm afraid of big waves i don't
mind them in the ocean but i'm not a
surfer
but i got pushed along and i actually
had to climb up a vertical wall uh
called china walls and with marathon
open water swimming you have to exit the
water
unassisted so if somebody took pity on
you and wrapped their arms around you to
just not knowing just trying to be
helpful you'd be disqualified right
there's all these there's all this it
goes beyond etiquette these are actual
yeah
rules and regulations that will certify
the accomplishment and that was
something that
you know the controversy that crept up
around diana nyaya yes swim from cuba
right because she would occasionally
hang onto the boat yeah yeah and so for
i follow what i what we call traditional
english channel marathon swimming rules
so
no physical contact with your boat or
your crew
um
no resting on the boat um people say
because you swim through the night
they're like oh so did you get on the
boat for a nap no
um no wetsuits no no
no shark cage uh no thermal cap has to
be a regular
latex or a silicone cap you're allowed
earplugs
i don't like water in my ears i'm like
i've seen those videos online where a
cat like accidentally falls into a
bathtub
like scrambles to get out like that's me
if i get water in my ears it's awful
well when the water's really cold it's
painful yeah yeah yeah
um
and so you know
with with that swim with molokai
um
i was like wow i've actually done two of
the ocean seven and i was like i just
got five more to go how hard can it be
and that's
uh there's no time limit like
in how like how long it takes you to do
all seven to be no okay and what and
what i love also about it is that
you know you're not competing with
anybody else like
sure you you become interested in what
other swimmers how long it took them to
cross that stretch of water just because
it gives you an idea of how long it
might take you
but there's no
uh it's just
that's what i love it's just you're
testing yourself
um and that swim was almost 20 hours of
non-stop swimming so when you're
swimming for 20 hours what are the
sort of mental
tricks that you employ to
you know remain focused when
you start to get tired or you feel like
you want to quit yeah yeah i mean lose
your mind yeah uh i think all of those
things have occurred but you rely on a
crew and
you know they
i pick my crew very very carefully there
are people that know me really really
well and they're also
i've learned a lot through being on
night train swimmers with the way veto
puts the teams together because team is
everything and it's not just
their connection with you as a swimmer
but it's their connection with each
other because it is a journey
it's really this odyssey
and so they become very in tune with you
know if you're struggling and so they
might offer me we call it a feeding so
every 30 minutes i have a carbohydrate
protein drink
or some snacks i experiment with
you know
whole food as well
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches yes
yes
and peaches like canned peaches oh oh my
gosh when you're out there
that is just i mean it's like dining at
a five-star restaurant when you have
something like that or um really easy to
digest yeah but it's just it becomes a
sensory delight because you're so
focused and then you have this thing
that just makes
everything in your mouth come alive and
mentally too it lifts you up but and
what is the carbohydrate protein drink
so
yeah so i've experimented with a bunch
of different ones um i use all goo
products now
um like the goo little gel packs
and their energy drink and then i take a
lot of amino acids
throughout my swim so i'm becoming more
scientific
in the past it's been
really
a hit and miss
but um
at the i always have what i call my bag
of tricks and i don't eat junk food but
you know i grew up with like candy and
that from new zealand and so it's this
bag of tricks which
if they know that i'm close to finishing
they can it's just pump me up with sugar
give me a mountain dew
right yeah i mean for that last leg you
can't do that you know if you're taking
gels early on yeah you can't in big
trouble yeah but those things work you
know i mean sugar works yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so
um
yeah so i have all those sort of
feedings and then just passing the time
when i'm
when i'm really
in my groove um i love
you know i see the boat i usually swim
on the starboard side and i breathe to
my left and i love to make eye contact
with the captain and then i just watch
the crew
the worst thing that can happen is your
crew form a huddle
because you know they're thinking about
what they're going to do with you
so you also become very devious well me
at least
when i swam across
um
from northern ireland to scotland that
was the hardest one right yeah that one
i almost died um
but i knew i was having trouble
breathing
but i knew that if i told my crew i was
having trouble breathing they'd pull me
so i
just adjusted my stroke and just
took a breath every stroke
trying to pull one over on the crew i
know right not advise that i know
but you know when you can smell scotland
when you can smell the grass of scotland
and it's a goal and that was my final
last one yeah and i mean all of us in
this sport are a little stubborn
um
maybe more so than others but when you
you it's a goal you've trained for it's
like you
i mean i end up in hospital after most
of my swims um
in america here i have great health
insurance and they know me on a first
name basis but cpmc
um
don't do this at home
and people just like why would you do
that but it's just
i just want to see what i'm capable of i
want to see how far i can go
and i've had the opportunity to do a lot
of that and
really like my soul has a lot more
wrinkles
you know through these experiences
so
let's go through the seven you did the
the new zealand one yeah cook straight
cook straight what are the other ones i
did the molokai channel right
then i swam across the strait of
gibraltar from spain to africa
um that was an amazing experience to see
a fisherman on the morocco side and um
i just said hello to him and he was just
like
um it's pretty rough right
and it's a big shipping
uh shipping channel
and then i swam across um the catalina
channel so catalina to the mainland
had dolphins escort me and towards the
end it was like the floodgates just
opened it was just there were thousands
of them accompanying me to shaw
and then
i was like okay i'm ready to do the
english channel because i told myself i
was going to go back there as prepared
as possible
and that swim was
a really
fabulous swim for me i wasn't sick
i felt happy the whole time and and
people make fun of me because
i mean i'm always so happy out there in
the water but i
again i'm like a 12 year old girl and
i'll i'll be swimming along and i'll go
whoa
you know it's just this expression of
just joy
and i was swimming across the english
channel it was as flat as a lake
it was gorgeous day and um
my boat captain um
he just would stick his head out the
window and he'd go whoa and he's just
like this you know he's just like a real
burly english guy
and uh
and then with that swim
he was actually just visiting here in
san francisco i've become very good
friends with him because you know he
your boat captains are responsible for
you
and they shepherd you across the sea and
after i'd done the english channel we
next day i invited him and my crew to go
take the ferry across to france and find
the spot where i made land
and he said in all the years he'd never
had a swimmer invite him to do that and
so we just had this instant bond and um
but it's just for me
these are not swims at all i mean
there's a swimming part of it but they
are
each of them are
journeys of the self
and the people that
are with you during these journeys are
forever
you know they forever have a place in
your heart
and and you learn gratitude um
and you learn
appreciation
but underneath all of this for you
is the the current of joy like joy is
feeling this for you it's not like
you're not coming into this with this
hardened like i'm going to prove that i
can do this coming from some kind of
unhealthy place like you're just you
just love it right like you're
this is what you're supposed to be doing
yeah right and when you're doing it
not only do you feel
alive you're completely in your in your
bliss
yes and i feel filled with purpose
because all of these swims i do for
charity
um and another great learning that i
i got from veto and night train swimmers
because we do swims around the world all
for charity and
and that's what i've incorporated into
my solo swims and so it's it's really
making these swims bigger than about
yourself
um
sure they're you're the one that gets
the accolades and um but i'm the first
to say that you know
i didn't do it alone and i share all of
these achievements with my crew um and
even the people that
you know someone at the club or someone
here in the city would just say like i
read that you're gonna go do the swim
like good luck like
just the fact that people are thinking
about it and then you know i have a gps
tracker on the boat and people can track
me real time on a google map
and i've had my colleagues at work on
their big monitors like track me and and
that helps you put them up on strava
no
you like i think you have the kom for
the fair launch but like yeah
nobody's gonna challenge that anymore
yeah yeah so it's just
the fact that people
are interested as well in a sport that
they might not understand that they
might not connect with like
i never used to understand why people
climbed mountains but now i understand
why people climb mountains
and um and that's because
they're journeys they're you are pushing
the limits of your physical and mental
self and i think also
many of us are afraid to do that because
a lot of times it's scary
and a lot of times it's uncomfortable
it's going to hurt and human nature is
to
avoid things that could potentially hurt
us that
could make us
cold could make you know
make us uncomfortable
but
when you
[Music]
when you and we all have fears but when
you really
push through those fears
um and again human nature is to is to
retreat from fear
when you push through
there is the sense of self there is a
real
in my case at least that's where the
treasure lies the treasure in life lies
right on the other side of where you're
most fearful
super powerful
yeah not only do we
sort of recoil from the uncomfortable
we're sort of haplessly chasing
these emotions that you're experiencing
joy
gratitude giving back through the
charity that sense of feeling alive
we're sort of encouraged to seek those
out through material possessions
or social status yes and that's what is
encouraged in our culture and the
messages that were sort of you know met
with on every billboard and every
television commercial and every magazine
right right and the truth lies in
shucking that aside yes and
doing something that scares you yeah
whatever that is and it doesn't have to
be you know
sweeping the english channel no you know
and it didn't start that way for you
either it started with you dipping your
toe into aquatic park that first time
yeah yeah
you know and even getting in that pool i
was most afraid of people looking at my
scars i mean
so silly but but we all have fears and
they're
different for all of us but i can
guarantee that when you
pick a fear you know we all have many
fears pick a fear and decide to
challenge it face on and you get to the
other side i
i guarantee you will have a
transformative experience that will
serve you for the rest of your life
um because again life is not smooth
sailing and i feel like through these
experiences i've been able to
equip myself with um skills and
lessons and how to deal with certain
things um
and then also just dealing with people
and and
yeah i mean i i i walk around every day
with a heart that's full
and
i just want to give back and i i want
everybody to feel it's just a little bit
of what i get to feel in order today i
mean i feel spoiled spoiled rotten
because
i am in this world that is
right where i
am supposed to be
and um
and then to be able to share it with
people and i love you know i love
talking to little girls and you know you
just see these sparks of possibility
light up in their head and
you know just knowing that
we're capable of doing far more than we
think we can
and it's just about deciding that you're
going to tackle something that might be
uncomfortable it might be a bit scary
how do you wear that mantle as
an inspirational
woman in a culture
in which you know in this sort of
kardashian-infused culture where the the
you know the influences on young women
and on girls is coming from that
direction right like
you know i've said this before on the
podcast but this idea that
that uh well there's no you know where
are all the inspirational women well
there's plenty you know there's people
like you there's lots of other people
you know anonymously
doing amazing things we just don't do a
very good job of shining a spotlight on
these people and and sort of elevating
them into mainstream consciousness so
that their influence can spill down to
the younger generation right so how do
you sort of you know think about that
and carry your advocacy to you know the
young the young women that you do
encounter yeah and i think the
difference for
women like myself who are
trying to show lead by example
is that you know we're
we're doing this for very um different
reasons we're not doing you know
we're not doing it for fame and fortune
um there's certainly no fortune um
involved in marathon over water swimming
but then i don't have nike calling you
offering you the multi-million dollar
endorsement contract but that's the best
you should yeah but that's the beauty is
that
you're driven by
it's pure it's pure
you're in it for reasons that are
meaningful and
you know i it does upset me to no end
the kardashian culture and idolization
of that um
that sort of life
it's very very sad and i'm sure
you know being a young girl
is
even more difficult than it was when i
was growing up
but i just hope that by continuing to do
what i do
that
one girl
at least
sees it and decides that she's going to
take a path and push herself
in a realm she didn't know she could do
that it's not about
fillers in your lips and
you know plastic suit yeah it's not
about that you know um
and and
and i know from my past experience
before all this happened to me that i
was very superficial and it was about
things like that
but
looking back
i was so hollow inside
like
i had no sense of
philanthropy or
helping others and
now because i i i do that and i feel
drawn to doing that i am like i said my
heart is so
full every day it's not to say that i
don't have bad days stressful days you
know we all do but
for the most part i just feel
that i know where my life is going i
know why i'm here
and if i can just
keep doing what i'm doing
and that it inspires you know
one girl two girls ten girls
um then that's pretty special that is
yeah so did we go through all the seven
no we didn't we didn't we're still
i had two left so i like to save say
that i left the best two for last
sugar straight which is between the
northernmost islands of japan from
honshu to hokkaido
that's exotic yes and they call that
stretch of water the flying dragon
that's what the locals call it because
the wind whips up there it's a
treacherous stretch of water there's
sharks there
um
but
i
you know i left it i wanted to be as
prepared as possible for that swim and
i'd learn japanese in high school and i
love the culture i just love the
etiquette and
the people and everything and so i was
very quickly connected with a number of
people there
including
some colleagues from adobe i work at
adobe
from their japan office and
i'd written a little blog post on our
internal newsletter and i said that this
is what i was planning to do and i put a
little i spoke in japanese and
i said you know
at the end sort of ingest
anyone interested in a little boat ride
i ended up with three colleagues from my
adobe office on my crew with my mum so
my mum from new zealand she is like my
chief crew
member
and people often ask her like how can
you watch your daughter go through so
much pain and suffering and
maybe get eaten by a shark but she knows
that hey i would do it anyways if she
wasn't there
but she understands that
if something happened to me that
that's
that would be the way i want to go
um
and so i had this crew from the adobe
office
and we met uh the boat captain the night
before
and the wind was sort of howling as it
is today actually in san francisco
and yeah for listeners you could
probably hear the wind going in the
backyard it's classic san francisco yeah
yeah yeah just need the fog horn yeah
exactly exactly exactly and so
yeah very similar to this the wind was
still sort of howling and
the boat captain who i'm
meeting for the first time the night
before my swim there's nothing like
putting your life in the hands of
somebody you've just met but um so veto
didn't come to this one no no no and
this was a local fisherman
and he barely spoke uh any english but
he was just the sweetest man and i
bought him a bottle of whiskey
as a sort of a a gift and i said to him
you know you can't drink this until this
one's over don't drink this tonight
yeah yeah yeah don't worry yeah but um
and
you know we
we started to talk about logistics and
then he said um
he said pulled me aside and he had this
sort of twinkle in his eye and he said
i think the dragon's gonna be sleeping
tomorrow
well went back to the hotel with my mum
and
the wind just started to die
and when it was time to meet the boat
very early that next morning there
wasn't a breath of wind
the dragon was sleeping and my swim
some the handful of people that have
completed the swim it's taken them
people that are faster than me
17 hours
that swim took me just over nine hours
the conditions were unbelievable
um and i got very very lucky because my
crew weren't experienced i mean they
were great
the great camaraderie and yeah well your
colleagues at adobe i don't know what
they're gonna be able to do if you ran
into trouble yeah exactly so that was a
bit of a gamble but um you know mother
nature was looking out for me and
when i finished the swim and i got on
the boat uh you know
i write about all my swims because i
want to remember them and it was
literally
minutes after getting on the boat the
wind just started to whip up and it was
just
i just sort of imagined that that was
the dragon's tail just kind of like you
know coming to life
and it was it was
it was just meant to be i mean i
mother nature blessed me that day um
the sharks are sleeping the dolphins are
escorting you yeah and the dragon
decides to take a nap yeah so the
universe is is definitely talking to you
i really feel that something has been
watching over me because um
you know then the next swim was the
north channel from northern ireland to
scotland and that's about 21 miles
the water temperature is 53 54.
and
you know so for these swims i'm bulking
up as well so
people have different theories on how
you can kind of um protect yourself from
the cold definitely
exposure to cold water helps you have to
just keep getting in the water every day
um
but having a little extra
weight um i call it be like a seal you
do i mean you don't see any skinny seals
out there do you you don't see their hip
bones
um
so i call it my insurance policy
and
having to shift the mindset uh from
being a ballerina has been um
hasn't actually been as difficult as i
thought i would have thought because
when you're out there in the ocean it is
life and death
and you want to come back alive and you
want to complete your swim and um
so i
for the north channel i was up to
185
190 i had back fat
there's a picture of me
getting in the water and i have back fat
you just eat everything in sight
everything
when i was not sleeping or swimming i
was eating and
i have a video of like the night before
my north channel swim with my mom and
my two crew mates and i'm eating
a uh a whole pizza and i'm like you know
this is uh this is a marathon event of
eating and this is not a glamorous sport
this is behind the scenes this is what
happens
but that's when
i was well prepared for the cold i i'd
bulked up and i'd been swimming
consistently in cold water i'd even i
lived in a little apartment by the
presidio and i had a backyard and i'd
ordered a kiddie pool on amazon i would
fill it with ice and water and i would
sit there in my swimsuit
for as long as i could reading magazines
and
my wim hof style yeah yeah yeah he's
amazing
and
it was very difficult and i didn't take
any warm showers for six months leading
up to my swim so at these clubs here in
san francisco the dolphin club in the
south end
when you come out of the water you have
a hot shower and then you get into a
warm sauna that's the way you warm up i
avoided all of that
but the big risk for that swim were the
jellyfish so they have these jellyfish
called lion's mane jellyfish and their
gelatinous
bells are sort of the size of a
the tyre of a mini cooper
and their
tentacles go 12 to 15 feet below the
surface i mean they look beautiful when
they're floating by at a distance
and
at that point only 26 people had crossed
the north channel
compared to over a thousand with the
english channel
and my captain said to me if you're
stung in the first hour the chances of
you completing the swim are pretty
um
unlikely
i got stung in the first hour
i didn't tell my crew because i was like
i just got to suck it up
and the pain is um
i mean
excruciating
but then it kind of subsides a little
bit and you know you sort of get in your
groove and you've got your endorphins
that are sort of helping take the pain
away
but what happened was i got stung
hundreds of times
it was like swimming through land mines
there was a point where my crew would
blow a whistle and i would know to stop
because there would be a jellyfish in
front of me a jellyfish on my right a
jellyfish on my left and so they're like
kim go back go back kim go left go left
go left and this is how they would
navigate me across the north channel
meanwhile my body is trying to fight the
toxins and um not focusing on keeping me
warm so i'm becoming hypothermic
i had trouble breathing i didn't tell my
crew um
i finished the swim
they hauled me back on the boat i don't
remember finishing the swim
and um my one of my best friends he was
on the crew his name's matt
and he had promised that he would shower
me with guinness beer when i completed
the swim and there's a picture of me and
i looked like a cadaver like i looked
dead
and
um he's smiling as he's like pouring the
guinness beer over me
and i warm up
uh we get back to northern ireland we go
back to the bed and breakfast
you know when you do these swims it's
like coming out of general anesthesia
you kind of have to be monitored just
you know and you're in pain so like my
mom took off my swimsuit she gets me in
the shower
and the bed and breakfast people had
bought us a bottle of champagne and i'm
having a glass of champagne in the
shower and it's just hot shower and it's
just luxurious and mum's sitting on the
lid of the toilet seat next to me just
to keep an eye on me and
then i just become really emotional of
to what i've completed i'd completed my
ocean seven
how long was the period of time from the
first to the seventh
two years two years yeah and so
six people have done it yeah and three
women right yep
yep yep yep i'm the sixth person to
complete it
and uh
i became really really emotional as to
what i had accomplished um
then i had significant trouble breathing
i was rushed to a respiratory ward
a local hospital there and then
i was there for a few days and
they finally discharged me because i
bounced back pretty quickly but then
they said what worries us about you is
that because you're so fit you're likely
masking symptoms that would not would
would be really apparent in an average
person
and that's what happened
um on the flight back here you know they
cleared me to fly i felt like i had
broken ribs
i was having trouble breathing and um
came back to my apartment my mom had to
fly on to new zealand and a couple that
oh my good friends they have a key to my
place and they let themselves in and
they're like what are you doing
i hadn't slept all night and i'm typing
just
gobbledygook on my computer
and they're like we need to take you to
hospital so then i go back up to my
friends at cpmc here and i'm in their
cardiac ward for a week
i had fluid both my lungs around my
heart it was pulmonary edema from
jellyfish toxicity
then everyone was like your swimming's
over like how many days after the swim
was that
about a week wow yeah about a week it
just everything like my body was able to
kind of keep things at bay for longer
than a normal person and
um
[Music]
that was
then i spent a month
in my apartment basically bedridden i
didn't work um
and people were like well you know
you're sw your swimsuit
you're done and is adobe like
like they seem like they're really
supportive oh they're fabulous
are they like okay
like we're totally into the fact that
you're doing all this stuff but like you
still have to like i know i know
no they have been my cheerleaders which
has been really special um
and and i've made a point of only using
my vacation time for these swims um but
that last one i had a medical vacation i
guess but but yeah everyone was like
well you know you should probably take
it easy
i think you're done with cold water and
swims and
but there was one swim that i wanted to
do and i wanted to do that when i fell
in love with those farallon islands
and i wanted to be
the first woman to swim from the
farallon islands
and not sort of like in a competitive
way but more because like
those are my islands like that's my
spiritual place and i wanted that for me
and um
that's what i set out to do
so how long after
the bedridden
uh jellyfish shock experience
before the farallon swim
11 months
yeah yeah and i got a clean bill of
health um
and i trained you know and with doing
these swims like you you your training
sort of
you know benefits the next swim and and
so on and um but that's when
you know as i'm talking to you i'm
looking at the golden gate bridge from
my window over there for the fairlawn
swim did you
take the boat out to the farallons and
swim back right so that was the
difference yeah and and i read somewhere
like this this moment of
like that that terrifying moment of when
you you're sort of standing at the edge
of the boat and you're gonna slip into
that dark water and the mystery that
that holds like oh not knowing what's
right underneath your feet i mean
i could have easily have slipped into
the mouth of a great white shark i mean
it was pitch black it was 11 15 at night
and to give you some context just 10
days before
my my training partner who's actually an
aussie so we have this aussie kiwi
rivalry his name is simon dominguez
very good friend of mine and he had been
attempting to solo the farallons but in
the direction nobody had done before
which is from the gate to the islands
um
and it's just
you know the tides are different it's
this both directions are tricky but
you know you're also going into that
ecosystem when you're tired um and for
him he was dripping blood from his neck
because the salt water can become so
abrasive
you know when you turn your head and
you've got the hairs on your back
he was dripping blood
his wonderful wife sally was on the boat
and one of his daughters and they
spotted a shark
he ended up getting circled by a great
white shark and they pulled him onto the
boat and he was three miles from
finishing
three
miles yeah but who cares
i know
yeah yeah and you know and i think he's
you know he came to terms with that
pretty quickly like he has his life
but that was sort of the the the the
backdrop for my swim
so people were trying to convince me do
not do the swim the sharks are back
earlier this year the time of year was
not great for this
no no but you know i
when i'm locked into something like
i'm gonna do it
and
what surprised me looking back there
wasn't a moment of oh yeah you know
maybe i should just yeah not do it
not at all which
is a little bit scary
i was committed to it
and um so that was why the sharks were
firmly on my mind and that morning
there'd been a shark a seal with his
head bitten off in that cove
so there'd been a predation there that
morning
um but yeah i you know i'm on the back
of the boat about to slip into that
water and um
my mum she's so sweet and funny
you know that the tension on the boat
was just palpable you know
and she sort of pops her head over and
she's like hurry up then get in the
water
and i'm like mom like just stripping
away like this just yeah come on yeah i
like mom um i'm just having a moment
um but she was just
that's great that she comes out and is
there for you and she's amazing yeah
she's 66 years old and she's got all the
gear the warmth because you have to be
warm and she is out there on the boat
watching me the whole time and cheering
me on
and um
she i mean she loves adventure too and
so she is she's my main crew person but
um
and that swim was just
i had swimmers escort me so after three
hours you're allowed to have a swimmer
join you for
an hour but they have to swim behind you
so you can't be accused of drafting off
of them and
so i just
the team was just an amazing group they
have a special place in my heart forever
and
you know coming underneath that gong
bridge
i will never forget and i'm in tears so
after every swim i've cried
and um there's a video of that of you
yeah yeah yeah and it's not sadness it's
just like
like i did that like i really
did it and it still makes me teary-eyed
today because
you know that i could see the pharahs
this weekend and
because it was so clear and
i mean it's madness i mean
it's pure madness but
we're capable of so much more than we
think we are and um
[Music]
you know came back to shore
to dock the boat there was media
everywhere and
um
but i'd vomited during the swim and
you know all i could think of was oh my
gosh i've just chummed the water the
sharks know i'm here now
um
and
i got on land and then i was sick again
and so they decided to um i convinced
the tiburon fire department to drive me
back to cpmc
from tiburon
um
but so my whole crew was like well you
know she's gonna be admitted she'll be
there for two or three days so we'll go
see her tomorrow
are they all i needed was four bags of
iv fluids
and then they discharged me at midnight
and um
you know all i was wearing was my
swimsuit that's covered in lanolin
because it helps protect against chafing
my hair is all just disheveled basically
you cover your whole body in like crisco
oil essentially yeah yeah it's a real
sexy sport
and there was that great picture in the
new york times yeah you covered it like
no there wasn't one
you know square inch of skin showing
your whole face is going in it and
everything yeah that was zinc oxide to
protect from the sun and uh yeah so who
would have thought my swimsuit glamour
shot would
new york times
um not exactly um sports illustrated but
um
you know and and
you know you're you just look disheveled
you look like
you're either
gone on some sort of bender on with
illegal drugs
and you look like you haven't slept for
a long time which you haven't so it's
not a good look
um they let me out of the hospital and i
they put me in a taxi and i sat on this
the the step outside my apartment
building and this is a this is a
street that's frequented by you know
people going to bars and everything so i
thought well i'll just wait there
because my mum she had the key and she's
tucked up here in my bed because she's
like well she's gonna be admitted to
hospital i'll catch up with her tomorrow
it's just normal yeah
and then so i had to wait for a drunk
couple to come into my building and i
think they were just like you live here
and i'm like yeah no i live here
and um
yeah and then it was just
i mean still you know but then what also
happens after these swims um
it's kind of this after drop
you know you you
you're striving for something and all
your focus is on it
and there's a couple days of
you're still in sort of this fog of
disbelief of joy
and then
there's a there's a
drop
like that that sort of um
[Music]
depressive state that comes in the
aftermath like that because there's a
vacuum right and you don't have that
goal anymore yeah and for me i found
that it becomes very lonely because
when you are out there in the ocean
you are dealing with life or death
and
not many people have experienced that um
and probably wouldn't recommend it but
you're looking because you've
connected it with life at such a primal
level
it makes it more difficult to connect
with people who haven't and it's not to
put me on a pedestal by any means it's
more that i have had
experiences that few people have had and
you you want to connect with people
at that level
um
so that's that's always been challenging
interactions become
less and less
yeah tolerable yes yes yes so it's just
there's so many learnings and it's you
know and even when i do sort of go off
this drop um afterwards it's sort of
i reassure myself that this is this is
part of the journey and um and to be
able to just feel those feelings of um
you
kind of feel like you're
your anchor is loose
and you don't know
instead of
so do you feel that urge or that pull to
then
set a big goal once again to fill that
vacuum yes
yes and i haven't
i haven't completely settled on my next
goal which is
frustrating for me because but it's i
think there's there's a teachable moment
in that too because how do you
find a way to
experience gratitude and joy and and
feel fulfilled
without having to live so extreme yeah
you know what i mean because so maybe
there's something there for you to learn
right because it's not um
i can't do this forever and it's
you know and it's
the the likelihood of it not ending well
is it gets higher and higher
well it i think it requires you to
examine it
and try to parse what aspect of it is
unhealthy versus healthy right because
there's definitely
that
you know as somebody who's prone to
extremes myself like you can you can
have an unhealthy relationship with that
right yes yes and you will be championed
for doing it and and and you will garner
self-esteem and all these positive
benefits of it but on some level there's
that tinge you know that light dusting
of sort of
of of
of maybe an inappropriate relationship
with it right and so absolutely
absolutely how do you find a new path as
you get older
right right because yeah absolutely um
because when you know that you are sort
of an all or nothing person and
you
give these adventures everything like um
you know when i train for them nobody's
telling me oh you got to wake up at four
and it's you're accountable for yourself
but i do everything that i possibly can
because i want to know that at the end
of the day
because mother nature is always the boss
um but the end of the day that i've
controlled what i can control
and that i can tell myself that i gave
it everything
because i would feel
disappointed in myself if i didn't give
it everything
um
so there's just so many lessons and
learnings and
it's a strange sport
but you have a gift now which is
these experiences and what you've
learned from them yeah and a platform
and a capacity to now
deliver that message
and service to other people yes right
and i think you can find a lot of that
this has been my experience you can find
a lot of that
contentment
um
in the giving back yeah you know like
that can fill the vacuum in a healthy
way yeah yeah and that's why i love
i mean i'm a talker so
i know you get out you do you do a lot
of public speaking and i love it i just
love it because
i want people to realize like
you know like i've said that you're
capable of doing far more than you think
you can and
sure i've done these swims that are
extreme and that doesn't mean that you
have to do them but it's just
motivating someone to think of their
life differently
and to see possibilities and to break
the chains of of
social expectations to give yourself
permission
to explore you know an interior and
exterior life that
lives outside of kind of what your
quote-unquote supposed to do or what
somebody else thinks that you should do
right right right because our lives are
pretty prescribed
um and to be able to step out of that um
and you might be surprised what you
learn about yourself and
equally the people that come into your
life um
i mean i feel like i just i live in this
little bubble
and
all these amazing people who i admire
and i look up to and
um
and they're just ordinary people we're
just ordinary people
i mean
we go to work every day we
have relationships we you know
but
we're able to
push ourselves
and learn more about ourselves like i
said my soul has a few more wrinkles
with every one of these swims and my
heart
is so incredibly rich
how would you articulate
uh
your relationship with fear and
overcoming fear
fear is a motivator for me
if i am afraid of something i know i
have to do it
um
it doesn't make it easy
and it's still scary
but i know
as i said earlier that
i know from experience now that
the treasure in life lies
exactly right over the other side of
where you are most fearful and where
you're most uncomfortable
and that's magic when you can experience
it for yourself
it's
magic and
so for me
fear is a motivating factor for me
i think that's a beautiful place to end
it
but i do want to ask you one more
question yes
for somebody who's listening to the
podcast who's maybe feeling stuck
in the rut of their own experience and
who has struggled with
trying to see their way through to a
more you know vibrant
fully actualized way of living
or somebody who maybe is
is sort of comfortably residing in that
self-imposed prison of fear
you know what are what are some steps
that people could take to
kind of uh
cut that chain and become more fully
expressed
yeah that's a great great question i
would say that because for me
doing these things that i'm fearful of i
haven't done it alone at all
i think it's about picking
an area that is
scary to you and finding
a community
that
partakes in whatever that activity is
right
because when you surround yourself with
it's about surrounding yourself with
people
that encourage it and say and don't
you don't want somebody to say well
that's that's really scary like you
probably shouldn't be doing that like
you know
surround find the people find the people
that are doing what you want to do that
are scary to you like
i'm terrified of big waves on the beach
terrified my friends make fun of me i'm
like how big of the waves are like
double over ankle i'm like what that's
too big
you know
um and i try to
surround myself with people that i try
and i'm trying to get over that fear by
getting back into that water but the key
is that
don't
try to do this alone
because it is about community it's about
camaraderie and it's about finding those
people who are going to say
why not
that's a great idea
and trusting your instinct right yes
whatever that little tickle on the back
of your mind is yeah it's bugging you to
go try something new because it's there
for a reason it's there for a reason and
knowing that you know what
as far as we know we've only got one
shot at this life
and um
to put it bluntly like
you just gotta suck the marrow out of it
because it's all we have and you know
tomorrow is not guaranteed for any of us
all we have is right now
and
i think it's up to all of us
we owe it to each of ourselves
to be the best
version of ourselves
and i can guarantee when you face your
fears and you break through those fears
you will get closer to being the best
you can ever be
boom
we did it that was so awesome oh thank
you oh it's fantastic thank you for
listening um i told you i was a talker
no it was great
you are an inspiration uh we need more
powerful women like yourself and
i just applaud all the things that you
have done but more importantly
um the way that you articulate them you
know i think i think people are going to
be really inspired by this and and your
message is super powerful so thank you
oh thank you for sharing it with me
thank you thank you cool so if you want
to connect with kim the best way to do
that is you can go to
kimswims.com that's your website yep uh
at kimberlyswims on twitter yeah right
yeah spelt the queensway
k-i-m-b-e-r-l-e-y
kimberly swims and also on instagram
yes
i'm part of the call and also
uh on instagram kimberly swims
thanks thanks so much awesome
peace
[Music]
you